world leaders are here in New York this
week for the United Nations General
Assembly former first lady that would be
Laura Bush once the spouses of those
world leaders to realize they've got
power to mrs. Bush will appear with the
first lady of Namibia at a panel
discussion later today here in New York
she has worked and traveled with her
part with her as part of the first
lady's initiative at the George W Bush
Institute it urges leaders spouses to
use their status to improve education
and health care for women and girls mrs.
Bush is here for an interview and we
like this part that you'll see only on
CBS this morning very good to see you
welcome good morning good to see you
good morning here well as you pointed
out in the green room listen you want to
vote you had a vote of only one that was
elected by one man elected by one person
well it is part of the problem is that
of course first ladies aren't elected
that's a and in many cases they don't
have a really institutionalized role in
the United States we do and have really
from the beginning so what was the
process for you when you were deciding
what you were going to do how you were
going to use that that office without
thinking is here and this is my advice
to first ladies to start with what you
know I mean I was the librarian I was a
teacher those were really you know
important things that have to do with
literacy and what you want children and
families to do together in fact right
before September 11th on September 8th
was the National Book Festival the first
National Book Festival that I found it
and you know a hundred thousand people
came to the National Mall there was such
a difference really between
that day and then two days later mrs.
Bush you point out of course there's no
rulebook that's right and the first
lady's not elected but you can have
enormous influence you really can't have
a lot of influence and we know that I
mean when we look at the history of the
first lady's that we've known the ones
that we've known in our lifetimes as
well as the ones who go on like Hillary
Clinton did to elected position after
that as Senator and then as Secretary of
State and now is the presidential but
should usually the last person at night
and the first person in the morning the
talk to the person who's making big
so what is your message to other first
lady I mean at least you had a
mother-in-law who could sort of traffic
I had a huge advantage that no one else
had because I'd watched my mother-in-law
in that role itself and then just
watched her all those years and then
I've been First Lady of Texas which was
also you know good experience for me but
Barbara Bush had a huge influence on me
just watching her and knowing she just
is so natural and I think that's what
people really appreciated from your
husband no shrinking violet from all of
her daughters-in-law what are you
finding that most first ladies as they
navigate these water what are the
biggest concern as they try to figure
out what to do and how to do Oh my
advice to them would just be come with
what you know you know start with what
you already and many of the first ladies
around the world that I know we're
business women already themselves are
had other positions and really had can
bring a lot to the to the their
countries and then of course in most
cases women also want to first ladies
want to support women and children and
that's important as well use their role
for that what's your proudest
achievement for what you did feel like
you were able to achieve in the eight
years in the White House well that's an
interesting question I don't know if I
really thought about it but I do think
that after September 11th when the
spotlight turned Afghanistan and
everyone looked and saw the way women in
Afghanistan were treated by the Taliban
I think being able to resonate with you
did resignated with me it resonated with
a lot of people in fact we started the
u.s. Afghan women's council right then
and Hillary Clinton joined the u.s.
Afghan women's council a perfect example
of what a first lady can exactly and it
was a way to bring attention to for me
to bring attention to the way women were
treated and I saw it around our country
I saw that women especially were
horrified with the idea of half of the
population of a country being left out
forbidden even to walk on the streets
uncovered and and I started hearing from
people around the country one of my best
friends called in
she said you know I used to be so glad I
wasn't in your shoes but she said now
I'm jealous because you can do something
Wow and that's when we really had the
idea to start the u.s. Afghan Women's
Council you know before Michelle go
ahead I was gonna say we've seen Melania
Trump out there with her husband you
know being the victims and Irma and your
home state to of Texas what advice do
you have for her well I don't have
advice for really I have met her I've
went to the White House for tea and she
very nicely had the entire White House
staff who are permanent you know the
butler's and the ushers and the chef and
everyone that I knew waiting in the
diplomatic reception room so I could say
hello to everybody you know Michelle
Obama had a funny line when she was
leaving the White House I'm paraphrasing
they said what are you most looking
forward to
and she said rolling down the window or
opening a window without people think
about when you first left the White
House what was it that you said now I
can finally do fill in the blank what
was that face well I did everything I
really wanted to do when I was at the
White House I went for walks on the
National Mall early in the morning but
with your Laura Bush face it yes and you
know a baseball cap or something with my
friend who lived there so I really did
those things I think it's like there's a
slight sigh of relief just because
you're not you don't feel so absolutely
responsible all the time and of course
that's what the president feels you know
what's interesting about politics among
many things it is how relationships can
transcend parties that's not one hand
Clinton and that's right Bush 41 on the
other hand President Bush and Michelle
Obama
there's Brandon they are well all the
press former presidents really and I
admire that about our country just the
ads that the former presidents made the
one America ads with first about
hurricane Harvey and then also about
Burma now that's about Florida but
you're Charlie's point they do seem to
have some sympathy
it's good to see and that's fun and
George was actually the one that but his
dad and Bill Clinton together when after
Katrina I think or maybe it was after
the tsunami
we ask them to raise money the unlikely
friendship well it's good to see you you
look good do you feel as good as you
look
I feel great yeah but I'm not really to
talk about this about first ladies so we
made a point that there is a real flower
yeah thank you very much so good to
share all of this too with not just
first ladies here but around the world
the world thank you very much